[Music]
a few days ago the twitter channel of
the witcher hosted the first footage of
the second season you can see richard in
a new armor which is much darker
and has new shoulder armor shortly after
there were also snapshots of siri who
can be seen in front of a snowy
background
and with a wooden sword the caption says
looks like someone has spent time with
the witcher
this is of course an allusion to the
fact that syria and gerald will travel
to karamorin in the coming season
analogous to the first volume of the
witcher book series
siri will start her training as a
witcher there which explains the new
outfit
and training sword the release date of
the second the witcher season is not
known for sure but is planned to be
released
in 2021 as constantine film announced
this week a resident evil film reboot is
currently in the works
in terms of content it will be strongly
oriented towards the first video games
of the series
as horror film director johannes roberts
explains they want to reproduce
exactly the experience that many people
had when playing the first two parts
at the same time the plan is also to
pack the whole thing into a down to
earth story about a small
almost extinct town nevertheless the
spencer estate in raccoon city from 1998
will be the center of attention
especially fans of the video game should
be pleased
since none of the films that have been
released so far have really picked up on
this terrifying mansion at the same time
most of the cast has been revealed so
caius scalda oreo
will appear as claire redfield hannah
john cayman as
jill valentine and robbie mel as chris
redfield also included are tom hopper as
albert wesker avon jojia as leon kennedy
and neil madonna
as william burking unfortunately there
is no start date for this reboot yet but
we will keep you informed about any
future news
a godzilla anime series is currently in
development for netflix
although not much is known about the
actual plot yet at least the signing of
the award-winning japanese sci-fi author
toedjo could be announced
for the visual design two well-known
designers were hired
namely blue exorcists creator kazu katu
and ijayamimori who had already worked
on spirited away after the godzilla
anime films planet of the monsters
and the planet eater we are definitely
looking forward to the series
the series will be called godzilla
singular point and is planned to be
released on netflix
over the course of next year the fact
that dune is postponed
should actually not surprise anyone
anymore the new start date has now been
moved by 10 months to october 1st
2021. as with many other movies before
this caused a chain reaction
also affected is the batman which is now
scheduled on march 4th
2022. the flash has been moved to
november 4th 2022
while shazam 2 will now be released on
june 2nd
2023 jurassic world domination will also
not get off scot-free and will now have
to be content with the u.s state
on june 11 2022. one film however
will be moved to the front namely matrix
iv
the blockbuster with keanu reeves is now
scheduled to be released
on december 23rd 2021 instead of april
2022 dc's superhero movie black adam
hits probably the hardest as this one is
now even postponed
indefinitely the one who was also
heavily affected is the world's second
largest cinema chain cineworld because
after many setbacks in recent months
they have decided to temporarily close
all cinemas in great britain and ireland
we can only hope that the small
and medium-sized cinema operators in
particular don't have to close their
doors forever as the hollywood reporter
exclusively revealed a few days ago
jamie foxx will probably return
as villain electro in marvel's
spider-man 3.
yes you heard it right the electro who
appeared in the amazing spider-man 2
with andrew garfield as spider-man
apparently the negotiations with jamie
foxx
are already close to completion which
means that electro
is a character from a completely
different film universe
this again could be an indication that
sony after many years of unsuccessful
attempts
will finally create its own cinema
universe around the friendly spider from
your neighborhood the agreement between
sony and marvel provides that tom
holland spider-man
may stay in the mcu for three solo films
but then
returns to sony since the first two
films homecoming and far from home have
already been revealed the contract is
fulfilled after spider-man 3. the hype
around spider-man
is at its peak at the moment due to tom
holland which is why sony could now make
a new attempt towards its own film
universe
there are still enough characters with
venom morbius silk
and madame web in any case some fans
even think that this
points towards a greater reunion with
tom holland andrew garfield and toby
maguire of course
this is all speculation and marvel
hasn't officially commented on it yet
however before the time could come this
still nameless
spider-man 3 is expected to be released
on december 17
[Music]
2021
bye